we're not positioned like this we're
actually positioned like this we're
tilted at an angle of 23.5 degrees the
reason why angles are really important
to astronomers is because at some level
it's all we can measure uh when you
actually go out and take a picture
whenever you take a photograph what
you're actually doing is recording a
whole bunch of angles and the only way
you can turn that into something more
physical like how big something is is
when you know how far away it is now the
symbol for degree is very simple
it's just a little circle like this
and that kind of tells you where the
concept of degrees come from because of
course we're measuring angles and we can
think of angles as just
divisions
going around a circle
grayscient means to me
in fact we do a lot of experiments right
at the other end of the scale where
we're interested in how atoms bond
together to form molecules and then
we're interested in bond angles so we've
got two atoms we're interested you know
if this atom's placed here is replaced
here if there's a twist or a torsion in
that and we use angles and degrees to to
measure that amount of tilting or
twisting now the choice of 360 is
there's nothing special about that
there's nothing fundamental about a
degree this is a symbol this is a unit
that we've invented because it's fairly
convenient if you see something that
looks very small it could be
intrinsically very small and quite
nearby or it could be enormous but on
the other side of the universe so it's
really only when you have that extra
element of knowing how far away it is
that you can start really understanding
the physics of what's going on but the
first thing you actually record when you
actually just take a picture with a
telescope or even with a camera is
you're recording the angular size of the
thing how many degrees does it appear on
the sky um so here actually is a work in
progress this is actually um some
what i call non-contact atomic force
microscopy experiments the results of
those and what we see each blob here is
an individual silicon atom and i guess
it's this one i'm most most interested
in because what we have here is
pairs of atoms we call those dimers
at this surface and remarkably they have
this buckled or zigzag
configuration as you go down the surface
and you can see that here bright one
darker one bright one darker one bright
one darker one we can sometimes be
familiar with with degrees
in terms of
units of latitude and longitude so if we
take the earth here
we've divided this up
into a
grid-like system of lines
now there's another very important angle
that comes into all of this which is
23.5
degrees
let's imagine that this this is my earth
here
and you can see the stem
acts very well as the north pole uh and
this is the south pole down here so
let's imagine that we're
we're on the earth so
we're sitting here in nottingham the
university of nottingham and our
coordinates are something like
56
degrees north
and 1 degree west if this is our equator
going around the middle we're going to
be up here somewhere so let's imagine
that this is us sitting here and nodding
up let's imagine this light bulb here is
the sun
now if the axis of the earth weren't
tilted we would be rotating around like
this
and that's very simple to realize you
watch the tack and you realize it has
daylight on one side of the rotation and
then it goes into night time as it
rotates away from the sun okay
but in reality and this is due to
however the earth and the solar system
formed we're not positioned like this
we're actually positioned like this it
has lots of implications um for example
one of the implica is the reason why we
have seasons
and we're tilted at an angle of 23.5
degrees
how many does it go i'm not sure
okay so we're actually spinning
something like this
and it's this tilt that gives rise to
the seasons
so the seasons don't come about because
we're we we're closer and further away
from the sun the seasons arise because
of this tilt when the earth axis is
leaning towards the sun at least in the
northern hemisphere that's when we have
sun summer and when we're leaning away
from the sun that's when we have winter
when the earth is at this position in
its orbit
we've got summertime in the southern
hemisphere and winter time in the
northern here in the hemisphere so this
is about december
when we're over here
it's the opposite so this is july we've
got summer in the north winter in the
south
so here the scale unlike megan's scales
here we're talking about instead of
parsecs and light years we're talking
about not just nanometers but actually
down to the picometer scale or hundreds
of picometer scale so 10 to the minus 12
of a meter the angle actually turns out
to be about when this in these buccal
diameters turns out to be about 18
degrees
okay so one neat coincidence about the
fact that our axis is tilted by exactly
or precisely 23.5 degrees
is that it means that we're always our
north
our north pole is always pointing in one
particular direction because the earth's
rotating um the effect of that when
you're sitting on the earth it makes it
look like the sky is rotating looks like
the sky is going around the other way um
and so one of the things that
astronomers have to worry about is where
in the sky something is relative to that
axis about which everything's rotating
so the pole star at the moment is sort
of pretty much right on that axis so the
pole star doesn't move very much
or it doesn't appear to move very much
because of the earth's rotation
okay so let's let's imagine that that
this room is full of stars and they're
much much further away from from us than
the sun is
um and as we sit here on our earth and
as the earth turns over the course of
the night we'll see that those stars
appear to move just like the sun appears
to move
as we rotate around
now our north pole on our apple actually
points to one particular star so let's
imagine that that motion detector up
there is the star i'm talking about this
is what we call the north star or the
pole star and there's absolutely nothing
special about this star it's a
completely ordinary star it can be kind
of hard to find sometimes if you don't
know what you're looking for
but we see it as being special because
of all the stars in the sky it's the one
that doesn't appear to move at least if
you're looking from the northern
hemisphere why not
simply because that's the direction that
that our north pole is pointing in so as
we rotate around all these other stars
are going to appear to be moving but
that one is going to be staying in the
same spot the pole star is not
absolutely exactly on the axis of the
earth on the on the extensions of the
earth's axis into the sky so although
the earth rotates about an axis that
points almost at the pole star
it's not exactly at the pole star and of
course the other thing that's going on
is the earth's axis is itself processing
over time so over tens of thousands of
years where the north pole is actually
moves so what's the pole star now in 10
000 years time won't be the pole star
anymore